y llegó el momento ahora de repasar los
titulares de la prensa en directo
américa para ello ya me acompaña en el
estudio como es habitual rosa pérez más
de rosa bienvenida feliz miércoles para
ti vamos a hablar de los 10 años del fin
de eta repasamos entonces como la prensa
española conmemora estos 10 años del
cese de la violencia en este conflicto
vasco rosa vamos con los medios que
vamos a comentar la vanguardia el mundo
público y él ya era punto es exacto raúl
arceo y precisamente diez años que se
dieron a conocer estas imágenes que
vamos a ver ahora diez segundos del
comunicado de que que publicó en la
banda que mandó al diario vasco gara y
que del que luego se hicieron
repercusión evidentemente medios
nacionales e internacionales veamos las
imágenes
es tiempo de mirar al futuro con
esperanza
es tiempo también de actuar con
responsabilidad y valentía
por todo ello está decidido el cese
definitivo de su actividad armada
hace 10 años ya de este vídeo rosa
entonces ahora sí empecemos con la
vanguardia los cinco momentos clave en
los 10 años del fin de eta exacto mira a
la vanguardia repasa cuáles han sido los
cinco momentos más destacables desde que
salió a la luz de este vídeo desde que
se publicó este vídeo y lo hace
repasando ciertos titulares del propio
medio en primer lugar pues el
correspondiente a este día al 20 de
octubre de 2011 que dice eta deja las
armas el presidente del gobierno español
que en ese momento era josé luis
rodríguez zapatero' recordemos del
partido socialista proclama la victoria
de la democracia de la ley y la razón en
segundo lugar como segundo momento
destaca el 28 de diciembre de 2013 el
colectivo de presos vinculados con con
la banda admite el daño causado ese fue
también un momento trascendente porque
se abandonaba también la petición la
idea de amnistía general y se admitían
las condenas y el estudio de los casos a
nivel pues individual pero también se
reclamaba algo que sigue hasta a día de
hoy que es la petición del acercamiento
de todos los presos a las prisiones del
país vasco en tercer y cuarto lugar
señala un poco el mismo punto y es el
cuando en 2018
eta anuncia por carta que disuelve
completamente todas sus estructuras y en
este artículo vemos también el texto del
comunicado pues en que se anunciaba la
disolución no ya absoluta de la banda
porque recordamos hace diez años al lo
que se comunicó fue el abandono de la
violencia armada y en 2018 fue cuando se
disolvió completamente la estructura y
por último el quinto punto que destaca
este artículo es cuando nada hace
precisamente 20 días el 1 de octubre de
este 2021 el gobierno del país vasco
asumió las competencias
de la gestión de las prisiones el vacío
es rosa ahora vemos cómo llega el
conflicto al día de hoy con los
titulares que hacen referencia a lo
ocurrido en esos días ros empezamos con
el mundo otegi tenemos sentados o presos
en la cárcel y si hay que votar los
presupuestos pues los votamos así así
titula exacto mira este este medio el
mundo es un medio que sabemos es de
derechas y muy antagónicos de tanto el
actual gobierno de una coalición del
partido socialista de podemos como
siempre muy crítico con la izquierda
independentista y lo que señala el mundo
es precisamente una referencia a lo que
comentamos aquí el mismo lunes cuando
tuvo lugar en a donostia-san sebastián
esta llamada declaración del 18 de
octubre en la que otegi este histórico
líder de la izquierda independentista
vasca
en cierto modo pues reconoció o no a las
víctimas de eta y dijo que su dolor
nunca debería haber tenido lugar pero
horas más tarde tuvo pues lugar un
encuentro también entre otegi que ahora
mismo es el coordinador de la rama
política de la izquierda independentista
vasca coordinada en bildu que tiene
representación en el congreso de los
diputados de españa y en una asamblea
junto a militantes de ahetze bildu dijo
eso precisamente que hay 200 todavía en
las cárceles y que pues necesitan tener
el gobierno de su parte para sacarlos
entonces recordemos que el gobierno es
que esto pues necesita un cierto
contexto político
pues el gobierno de españa es una
coalición entre socialistas y podemos
que no tienen una mayoría en el congreso
de los diputados por lo tanto para tirar
hacia adelante ciertas iniciativas son
leyes necesarias como es son los
presupuestos del estado necesitan de
alianzas con otros partidos por ejemplo
con bildu como también lo hacen los
independentistas catalanes de esquerra
repúblicana estos partidos que dan su
apoyo al gobierno español piden ciertas
cosas a cambio por lo que pues aquí se
enmarcan estas declaraciones de tecla
así de rossi también para los
televidentes un dato rapidito antes de
pasar por el otro periódico hay una
serie muy buena que se llama patria
donde explica todo este conflicto vasco
ahora vamos con público sánchez ha
casado en el décimo aniversario el fin
de la audiencia de eta no entiendo como
la derecha no lo celebra a rosa exacto
no pues también esto es un titular que
hace referencia a hoy mismo cuando esta
mañana en la sesión de control al
gobierno en el paro de españa pues el
líder de la derecha de tradicional el
pablo casado ha echado en cara a pedro
sánchez pues que quisiera
sucumbir un poco a las peticiones de la
izquierda independentista vasca
sánchez ha negado que su intención fuera
la de liberar a los presos que están
condenados por sus vínculos con el
terrorismo de eta pero sin embargo
sánchez ha recalcado que no entiende por
qué la derecha no se alegra de esta
década de paz en el territorio español
diario punto es jonathan powell mediador
del fin del fin de eta el pp puso en
peligro este proceso de paz rosa exacto
pues queríamos cerrar un poco esta
sección dedicada a la cobertura
mediática de esta década de paz con una
entrevista a una de las personas que
intervino en esta mediación
internacional entre lo que era el
gobierno de españa' en ese momento
liderado por los socialistas y pues
etanol a la banca la rama armada
de la izquierda independentista vasca en
ese momento y en lo que señala es que
pues el gobierno española de los
socialistas dice tuvo mucha valentía
también la tuvo la izquierda
independentista vasca la izquierda
'abertzale' sin embargo dijo la derecha
tradicional el partido popular puso en
riesgo este acuerdo de paz cuando asumió
el poder pues muy poco después de este
anuncio que ahora estamos recordando y
hace una similitud con lo que sucede
precisamente aquí en colombia cuando
tras un cambio de gobierno el gobierno
no entrante no tiene pues el mismo
compromiso con los acuerdos de paz y eso
pone en peligro lo conseguido hasta la
fecha así es rosa muchísimas gracias
entonces por todo este contexto de lo
que fueron estos años de violencia
independentista en el país vasco en
españa y a 10 años no que se disolvió
esta guerrilla de esta rosa muchísimas
gracias a por toda la información media
mañana con más titulares de la prensa
vamos ahora con nuestro tema del día
[Música]